this one's a little special this last
one boys this is Victor all right it's a
boy Victor
all right big Vic hi guys
Victor him from Sweden Sweden this is
possibly sync by Inc what do you think
about face tattoos I guess my first one
when I was like 21 and it got a lot
worse or small or what do you think I
also got this one buzz buzz buzz buzz
does that's full of good decisions I
look how I go dude yeah feel vaunteth
you [ __ ] yeah dude so make a decision
bro that's crazy man is that definitely
give you an angry Meg Ryan is punched in
the face and she's got a lot of work
done so you can't tell dude dude I feel
better than we get to meet this guy in
Sweden I was in Sweden I was in your
country maybe he came to show
I feel bad if I don't get to meet him
though yeah it's all move dude
wow man that's brave first of all you
definitely like up top you seem like
you've like you uh like just got a gang
banged a bunch of squids really a lot of
tats man it's brave of you I can't
that's that's why I think oh it's just
it's just brave I don't know what you do
for work but once you start going on the
face it limits your options to make an
income I think it does for suffer and
older for our generation for like
younger generation bro I think they can
do whatever I don't think so you don't
think so huh I think there'll be a
president with a face that yeah future
future oh wow I like your positivity but
that ain't happened but see that's
Armand said if you go with the
Millennial mindset do with the ego
smoking somebody drugs they don't
[ __ ] that's right this euphoria just
[ __ ] up each other
I'm worried about their man anyways this
guy I like it it's that's my thing it's
brave dude to get that smile celeb read
a it says I'm and then on his eyebrows
this says stage room true stay true to
your jaw I say this mount now this
gentleman has beautiful eyes I need to
get my size in his head
good-looking dude man and so tattoo
you're here damn bro the blue color
looks good with the blue eyes you know
so he's at least fashionable I could say
his good taste gotta tattoo a view on
his leg yeah it makes good G so we have
a good taste let me make a smart
decision I'll hustle every day as
written on his forehead dude I like it
bro I like the I hustled a huge ego and
then family on the forehead hmm
I said some questions what do you work
are you a tattoo artist that would make
sense
now that would make sense if he works at
the Apple store that's right yeah are
you a huge fan of the movie venom and
decide to get all this work done you
know and trying to look like Marty I
think it's pretty cool man if you think
back to Native American they got a lot
of things tattooed on their body things
written on them anything that meant some
yeah you know and it worked out for them
it took that early elbow what make you
said hey yeah yeah he's doing but - wait
where's everybody going that's a have
killed him with yep and now you know
they have casinos and stuff but still
you know it's just a [ __ ] table it's
not the same in imagine beat if you're
Native American walking around and being
like oh man this used to be like my
great-grandparents
land and now it's and then what Ryan now
some ansible a CBS on it ruin it it
really is kind of true you know it's
heartbreaking bro that's life doing it
well I mean that's some of the
old-school life where people were just
beating each other for land like you
can't do that any kind of take over
mm-hmm
trying to take over now you can't go
beat somebody for land you know yeah but
yeah that's where you could do it like
legally oh yeah Tiny's a Persians do
though beat you down for land bro that's
what I'm saying this coronavirus or
whatever if the Chinese built it this
[ __ ] will fall apart in three weeks
you think you god you'll never get it
and then had nobody coming near you but
also let's keep the walls up around
trying to do we don't you look like pigs
handler bro that is a big reference dude
yeah a little creepy but still good
reference
yeah creepy guy also knows what I'm
talking about yeah kid - ok give to kids
yes Jesus man shoutout to this dude for
making good decisions though gang [ __ ]
bro you got eyes dude god bless Sweden
bruh will see you as soon as things get
bad over here that virus hits here I'm
headed to Sweden dude bro the only that
virus is what you're gonna catch dude
billy-ray thyroid over here you look
like the biggest magician Africa damn a
little more butter on that bridge dance
more gravy on
[Laughter]
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching